last time this man was on from nbc
sports boston tom curran was on and we
had some fun with him because we're like
somebody's gonna eventually have to ask
bill the question about when are you
gonna tell us who the starter is
okay who's that person gonna be right
and then last week it was uh chris
gasper of wcvb asked him
and uh and bill kind of sticked it aside
and we broke it down
that press conference give and take
so best to our knowledge tom hasn't
asked the question yet
so i guess chris did you know did it
last time now that was the last
preseason game
tom took a shot at it i do believe today
and the uh the the rounds made it on the
nfl network media group uh email chain
about you know this happened that
happened that's what bill had to say and
i came to work today listening for the
soundbot i had no idea it was tom
but here let's check his work before he
joins us on the program here this is
this is tom asking the question of bill
today as we sit here trying to figure
out who the starting quarterback would
be
isn't it better for you to drag out
giving that intel to the miami dolphins
so they don't know this isn't like
baseball we have to announce it um
do you have to announce who your
starting quarterback is to the world
and is there an advantage in your
preparation if your opponent doesn't
know freeze it
okay well so tom great question tom went
multi-layered approach he went with a
barrage of questions a couple of them
yes or no but the one key one was to go
with the strategy
about someone else
trying to think he went cat and mouse
not just like when are we gonna find out
like straight through the front door
what are you tell us like don't you do
you not have to tell us like isn't it
better for you to not even tell us i
mean just i mean there's so many levels
i don't even know if that's four
dimensional chess
all right here's bill's response
yeah again i would just say tom that
what we're going to do is what we feel
is best for our football team and that's
what it'll be
so that's really the bottom line
there's a lot of different things to
talk about but
but whatever it is it'll be what we feel
is best for the team
like like we always do
yeah and wouldn't be best for the team
to keep that under wraps
what would it be best for the team to
know
what the situation is at certain
positions
yep
we'll do what's best for the team
performance art
well done and here to talk about it is
the uh the author himself
tom curran of nbc sports boston well
done tom well done we're just just out
here carrying parrying sucking weaving
trying to figure something out to get
him out of this
like fishing for that way
legendary lunker at the bottom of some
pond and you're just trying to get them
out get them out get them out and you
can't do it
you tried you tried you went at the king
you didn't miss i don't think you missed
but i mean i i like the whole idea like
why even tell us you know what what a
what a what a way to come at it that's
almost like the mets thumb down thumbs
down in their fans almost well
that's why because we don't want the
answer yet i mean we got two weeks
before the first game
we're gonna talk about if we find out
it's cam newton just [ __ ] about it
i mean yes
tom yes
because it should be mac jones i mean
come on we all watch the games
here's the wild thing on this when you
think is bill burr still there
no that was that was for him uh we
played that from a previous uh time the
great
how funny is he he
he his one of his producers is a is a
big patriots fan and sure likes our
podcast so he came on as a favor to me
and like i tried to make a couple jokes
with them going back before you get to
like you're not the comedian okay
um but here's the interesting thing when
you look at the numbers
of what cam has done in the last week
miss five days
missed the wednesday practice
through four
passes in 11 on 11 competitive work on
thursday through five passes on sunday
and took two drives the week before he
threw nine passes and took two drives
against the eagles
meanwhile
matt jones is taking
all the reps against the ones on
wednesday
he's taking all the drives last night
ends up throwing the boxing 22 times
um
this is the preparation of a starter not
the preparation of a backup so
regardless of when cam is getting rolled
out there at the beginning of drills or
at the beginning of preseason games
i continue to fall back on
it doesn't matter
who's out there at the beginning it
matters who's getting the work and cam
newton has not
gotten the work of a starter
hmm
so
what do you think he's starting i don't
think he's gonna start
i think he's going to go with matt jones
it's just it's completely
i mean i went back to 2001 in the 2001
season
through bledsoe's second year under
belichick
bledsoe played in the fourth preseason
game and he ran seven drives in that
game
and he threw the ball i think it was 19
times or something like that
he threw the ball 63 times in that
pre-season this is true bledsoe
nine-year veteran who had been in the
system
um you know it played under charlie
weiss who was now his offensive
coordinator again
and he threw the ball 63 times cam's
thrown the ball 21 times
he hasn't run it yet
i just don't think that any of the
indicators are that this is a player
who's been prepared by the coaching
staff to start games
we just haven't told them yet it just
makes kind of sense to me that cam is
there if the rookie uh gets hurt
the season's not over the season's
absolutely
significantly there still right and is
there as an opportunity
if necessary he's tremendous
in that opportunity in that role he also
makes the money for somebody in that
role it just
it fits that if mac jones has the
concepts down and the run game
and the line can protect him
that you might as well just start the
whole clock right now
the dolphins are very difficult test
it's home
then you've got the jets week two might
as well get his feet wet right there
that's on the road for the zack wilson
home opener
and then new england's third game for
the patriots is i'm trying to look this
up right here
houston no it's new orleans i mean
that's kind of a tough one at home and
then then you get mac kind of up to
speed in time for the whole country
tuning in for brady's return
i mean i you know i
i just don't if y'all what are you
afraid i mean bill belichick has never
operated afraid i have great
respect for the amount of time you spent
with him i can't even imagine how much
you must have learned about him during
the the nfl 100. it was fascinating
and i don't profess to to know other
than just
watching him uh love the game and know
it i mean like honestly you start to
watch how his mind works that's part of
the reason what i'm so fascinated tom
about what
he's leaning on what he's looking for he
definitely has to know how it's played
out in other places when he's either
been there for it or has known about it
he's had he's talked so much ball in his
life
he must know
something that he's looking for or
seeing or some gut feeling i'd love to
know the process
the kid is such an outlier
he is so he's not jimmy garoppolo i mean
he's not
jared stood up
i don't think he's even justin herbert i
mean the hiccups that he's had he had a
delay yesterday and he mismanaged the
end of the half last week
but those are really you know hang nails
on an otherwise
perfect body of work that he's put
together i mean he's been
accurate you look at all the pff numbers
in terms of interceptable passes and
um you know all the
more advanced analytic stats he's not
just with the rookies he's among the nfl
leaders in the preseason and again it's
the pre-season he's going against twos
but he's running with twos and it's the
same thing that we're seeing when he
goes with the ones in practice to go 35
for 40 on a 90 degree day rich
last wednesday in a two and a half hour
practice when he never came off the
field
except for a couple with hoya came in
that to me put it to bed so why do what
unless bill belichick is suddenly
coaching scared
and he's afraid that max gonna come
undone
and he instead wants to go with a guy
who can be a real threat with his legs
but is an absolute dice roll every fifth
row
and
doesn't have the same
acumen that you're accustomed to with
the line of scrimmage
it's improving and he's improved cam has
but it's still not where you want it to
be
why why would bill be so afraid to put a
player out there i my guess is
bill is calling a guy like nick saban
right now right rich
is this kid really this good is he gonna
be able to handle i think he's already
had that conversation though with him he
wouldn't have drafted him if he wasn't
already i'm sure he and nick have had
enough conversations about
about mac again i don't i don't know
he's probably just obviously i
and we're i'm throwing a dart at a board
here because again you know i i've i've
covered the guy and talked about him and
then i had that 48-hour 70-hour exposure
to just being around him the way he
talked and the way he
he was but but it was also a show about
history he knew everything about
everything and about everybody and was
able to basically talk about yeah i told
my team about this time in the 1989
you know nfc championship game or 90 nfc
championship game or this is what
happened once when i was coaching for
parcells and that's what happened with
marcia broda and he's got that whole
incredible library of knowledge and
history that he downloads to his team
which is why they're also terrifically
you know prepared and situationally
brilliant in a way that other teams
aren't
um but uh i i don't know what he's
looking for he might just go on his gut
and field and it might be something that
he he leans on somebody else i don't
know at all just for confirming his
belief and also he also saw what brady
looked like in that training camp that
led to bledsoe getting to start until
week two and
right the his the story goes that brady
had to have the better training camp and
and so you know 100 percent did i mean i
i'm sitting there every year can't
because he looks better than the other
guy and that's part of the reason but so
was out there
until as i said almost half time of the
fourth preseason game brady was
pummeling him in the competition but
bledsoe just signed a 10-year 103
million dollar contract
you know eight months earlier so we
weren't saying he's in trouble
but to me when we look at the concrete
things
the number of reps the amount of time
that he spent on the field
um the number of throws he's had how
he's looked what his teammates are
saying about him
it points to him mac jones starting when
we point to
cam starting what really recommends him
the fact that he's started three
preseason games been out there first
and then the first guy in in drills
and the bill said he was the starter and
then he started attaching caveats to it
as the time went on so i'm going to
believe what my sniffer's telling me
and if he doesn't start
then this was not a merit-based
competition
there was something else
that bill was beholden to whether it be
i'm afraid of mack getting
you know ruined or i feel loyalty to
camp
tom curran here on the rich housing show
before i let you go that you know the
topic du jour um in sports is you know
javi baez flipping the the thumbs down
and a handful of mets a couple of mets
doing that and we find out it's their
way to you know um band together uh
against fans that have booed them while
they were struggling
was brady ever booed in new england have
you ever heard brady get booed
um at gillette did that ever happen at
any time yeah the team got booed at
halftime i think of the denver game in
13
when they fell behind 24-0 and
ultimately come back and win the game
right the punk drop in overtime but i
think there was some booing as they
headed into halftime and they also fell
behind the niners that year 24 nothing
by halftime in a colin kaepernick
authored game
so there were booze then and i'm sure
there were booze in 0-9 because
the uh ravens beat them 33-14 in the
playoffs
and it was a bloodbath early on but
i think booing is to me
they're not repudiating you as a human
being they're weighing in on your
particular performance at that moment
and it's entertainment we're not friends
i mean
it's just i paid my
for my ticket i drove in here i sat in
traffic i bought an eight dollar hot dog
in a six dollar drink
and i'm sitting here in the sweltering
sun with sweat going down my back and to
my crack
and you guys stink
so
so brady has been booed in gillette but
you had to you had to really sit there
and think about it and it wasn't
particularly brady it was just the
collective patriot team it was just the
collective
all right and it was scattering booze
i'm sure that there were some people who
had dogs named brady and brewski
don't do that
chiklis whose birthday it is today um
hey thanks for thanks for
asking the question today uh so i guess
what's the ultimate do you think we'll
know do you think bill is going to just
keep it to himself like why would brian
flores need to know shouldn't know
right i really think he said a couple
things today that i that i thought were
indicative that he's going to probably
make the decision before the end of the
week okay um which is too bad because i
just put a bet on it uh with michael
felder
uh media mogul up here that he wouldn't
announce it until uh sometime in the
future okay
we could lose his bet tom thanks for the
call we'll chat okay yeah look for it
again that's tom e curran as he's known
on twitter i follow him you should as
well hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here